[Musique]
votre cinéma dans tout ce cinéma
un soulagement pour les clients du
nouveau cinéma ugc de plaisir qu'ils
peuvent enfin retourner dans leur salle
une attente beaucoup trop longue pour
certains amoureux du grand écran n'ont
passé beaucoup de temps au cinéma voir
deux voire trois fois par semaine
souvent les après midi ou en soirée les
week-ends voilà donc c'est plutôt cette
prévision là qui va qui va arriver
reprendre le rythme d'avant exactement
on va rattraper le temps perdu il ya
plein de films qui nous attendent et
qu'on attend des spectateurs qui
acceptent les quelques mesures
sanitaires en place pour leur permettre
d'accéder aux salles six personnes
maximum d'eux-mêmes lien social avec
deux sièges d'écart par groupe
tout ceci pour respecter les jauges
gouvernementale on respecte
scrupuleusement toutes les règles
sanitaires qui nous ont été édictées
avec un protocole strict très strictes
une jauge à 35% qui sera applicable
normalement jusqu'au 8 juin prochain y'a
pas faire du neuf on passera à 65% à
l'ugc de plaisir ce n'est pas une
réouverture mais bien une ouverture un
premier acte estivale pour le cinéma qui
s'annonce mouvementée tout ce qu'on
entend comme message de sympathie se
transforme aujourd'hui par la venue des
nouveaux spectateurs à l'ugc plaisir
donc moi je aucune crainte pour
accueillir les clients et je pense
qu'ils seront là en nombre plus
particulièrement cette année il ya
beaucoup de sorties jeux j'en retiens
deux qui sont très attendus le 21
juillet où vous avez une camelote et le
4 août normalement vous avez oss 117
pour ces deux films français qui sont
très attendus et qui je pense donc
retrouver et trouver largement leur
public même en période estivale entre
les longs métrages d'aignan pu
bénéficier que de quelques jours de
diffusion en octobre 2020 et les
nouvelles sorties
onze films sont à découvrir dans les
neuf salles de plaisir cette semaine